janisch ist das eigentlich dein
traumberuf interviews auf der straße zu
machen ja es ist zu meinem traumberuf
geworden
am anfang war das einfach etwas weh
taten so ein projekt oder eine übung und
weder mit der zeit ist mir klargeworden
das ist aber sehr interessant und das
ist ein riesiges privileg das machen zu
dürfen überhaupt die gehe auf die straße
und frage menschen ob sie mit mir reden
wollen ist das nicht toll und treffe
ständig neue leute und ich liebe es
das machen wir auch heute wieder und
tatsächlich ist das auch unser thema wir
fragen heute was ist dein traumberuf los
geht's los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ist ihr traumberuf mein traumberuf
was der wäre zum beispiel oder ist oder
sein wird
olala ich glaube hebamme warum oh je
ja weil das auch ziemlich stressig sein
können ja aber ist ja auch sehr
beglückend sehr sinnstiftend was wäre
ein traumberuf
möhlmann und warum trägst du dafür weil
ich dann jeden tag wüsste was ich
gemacht habe und dass ich einen job
mache der gut für alles ja und ich
glaube als müllmann hatte man so richtig
angenehm feierabend jetzt gehe ich nach
hause
trinke vier bierchen und also also ich
würde es halt ohne bier machen so aber
es ist ein job du bist draußen an der
frischen luft du hast körperliche arbeit
und wie gesagt ich würde jeden abend wie
du schon sagst nach hause kommen und
wüsste was ich getan habe und könnte
zufrieden einschlafen
was ist ihr traumberuf traumberuf das
ist lewitan das ist ein fliegender
mensch und wie stellen sie sich das vor
wie würden sie damit geld verdienen ja
geld braucht dazu kein
wohin geht und einfach in der luft und
schwebt daher und lässt die stunden
vergehen
was ist ein traum wäre mein traumberuf
ist lehrerin oder trainerin
ich habe keinen konkreten traumberuf
meinen beruf muss irgendwas mit bildung
zu tun haben
mit im weiteren sinne basteln ich muss
was schaffen es muss was entstehen und
leute müssen dadurch lernen ich bin
historiker das ist mein traum hoch
und wie fühlt sich das an was er fühlt
sich was freut sie an ihr arbeiten wenn
ich zusammenhänge finden kann in der
geschichte die bisher noch niemand
gesehen hat
mein traumberuf zb als kleines mädchen
was ich werden wollte
ich wollte immer nachrichtensprecherin
werden das ist aber wirklich ein guter
beruf das ist ein schauspielberuf man
muss die stimme üben und hast du das
tatsächlich dann auch ergriffen und nein
ich habe mich leider nie getraut und
immer viel theater gespielt aber dazu
ist es leider nicht gekommen aber ich
bin jetzt in der kommunikation tätig
also reden geht immer noch ganz gut
[Musik]
mein traumberuf ist irgendwas mit kunst
beziehungsweise also das sehr weitläufig
ich bin ja gelernter illustratorin und
ich mache das auch sehr gerne und
designerin eben auch aber ich einfach
sehr vielseitig also ich bin da sehr
interessiert in dem bereich und kann
neben auch andere sachen vorstellen aber
grundsätzlich alles mit kultur kunst so
mein traumberuf wäre es filme zu
animieren
ich denke ich wie macht man das man
zeichnet ganz viele wilde hintereinander
bis daraus einen film entsteht
und dann hat man hoffentlich ein kleines
video was ist ihr traum bin werde ich
nicht machen
und was ist das für ein berühmter
coaching wie was macht man dann
man arbeitet mit führungskräften und
hilft ihnen ihren leadership skills zu
verbessern
mein traumberuf ich hatte ihn er hat
mich nicht erfüllt und jetzt bin ich
rentnerin und damit sehr froh erzählen
sie von diesen beruf kassierten den sie
hatten ich habe journalistik studiert
und war redakteurin und das hat mich
nicht erfreut
und was war der grund dafür weil die
realität und das was man schreiben
sollte sehr auseinander klappt und das
war dann gehe ich davon aus noch in der
ddr
immobilienkaufmann keine ahnung
und warum ist immobilienkaufmann zu ein
traum von weiss bereits ausübe ja es
begeistert mich halt komplett erzählt
warum weil das ist nicht so was wir
erwarten normalerweise und deshalb
möchte ich gerne wissen warum ist das
führt warum machst du das zu sehen
stabile arbeit in jeder marktlage
[Musik]
kundenkontakt man das draußen menschen
ja und jeder üblich und in aktion ist
ein kleines abenteuer oder kann ich mir
vorstellen was ja könnte man so sagen
und man sieht schöne dinge ein
traumberuf
ich werd mich gerade im personalbereich
als personalmanagerin und der deswegen
ein traum wenn es klappt ja wir drücken
ihnen die daumen
und was interessiert sie an diesem beruf
ich arbeite gerne mit menschen zusammen
und unterhalte ich mich auch gerne mit
menschen und fährt raus genau was sie
interessiert warum sie etwas gern mögen
was was sie gut können was sie nicht
können
ich interessiere mich immer für
lebensläufe was man schon in der
vergangenheit gemacht hat und so und ich
denke das passt einfach gut ist auch ein
bisschen psychologisch der und natürlich
interessant ich würde gerne und
mediendesigner werden und wirst du schon
auf dem weg dahin
ich bin nicht so eine ausbildung machen
dieses jahr ist leider nicht geklappt da
weiß müssen spät dran aber nächstes jahr
soll es losgehen
genau und wie stellst du dir diesen job
vor warum warum ist er deinen traumjob
was erwartest du
an der ja ich möchte einfach also ich
hab viele andere jobs gemacht so
kleinere jobs tritt gern einfach ein
bisschen mit kreativer ausleben können
und deshalb möchte ich in so eine
richtung gehen
[Musik]
hallo
darf ich ihnen eine frage stellen bitte
sie helfen menschen beim deutsch lernen
und hast du es dir schon ganz früh
vorgenommen ich möchte als lehrerin
arbeiten und dann das umgesetzt was hat
sich eher so entwickelt hat einfach
gemerkt dass das nicht stärker
meinerseits ist und dass es gut mit
menschen arbeiten kann und es macht
einfach sehr viel spaß wie sind sie dazu
gekommen diesen beruf auszuüben weil das
ist ja kein beruf von dem sie mit 14
schon geträumt haben oder ich bin da so
reingerutscht
also ich habe eine corporate gearbeitet
und
bin dann hat eine ausbildung gemacht
psychotherapie coaching und wie fühlt
sich ein traumberuf an
na wenn im besten falle macht man das
jahrelang einfach gerne und hat auch
lust sich immer weiter zu entwickeln in
dem bereich und interessiert sich
einfach für das thema und man hat immer
ein gutes bauchgefühl wenn man dabei ist
so aber wie würde sich das anfühlen
einen traumjob zu zu wissen ich habe
einen traumjob das habe ich erreicht und
das liebe ich jeden tag großartig da ist
man ja mit sich dann in großer ein in
großen anklang
wenn man den beruf ausüben kann dem man
wirklich liebt
besser kann es ja nicht sein und
gratulieren sie sich selber jeden tag
wie gut dass ich diesen beruf ja ich bin
happy den beruf sagen auf jeden fall
glücklich mich hat das etwas wollen wo
gruber was wichtig ist im leben ist dass
man jeden tag auf weckt und denkt gut
dass wir diesen beruf habe ich denke ja
also ich hab es ja noch nicht aber ich
finde das wichtig um mit einem guten
gefühl jeden tag aufzustehen und ins
büro zu gehen
es hätte mich ein albtraum wenn das
nicht so wäre wenn man immer schlechtes
gefühl hat der für mich ist es wichtig
und jetzt könnt ihr aktiv werden und
euer deutsch üben schreibt uns bitte mal
auf deutsch hier in die kommentare
was ist denn euer traumberuf und habt
ihr diesen traumberuf schon erreicht
oder arbeitet ihr noch daran unser
traumberuf ist auf jeden fall weiter
videos für euch zu machen und dabei
könnt ihr uns auch helfen nämlich indem
ihr ein mitglied werdet als mitglied
helft ihr unserem projekt wir
finanzieren unserem projekt vor allem
durch mitgliedschaften und ihr bekommt
auch was dafür nämlich jede woche
interaktive übungen transkripte vokabeln
und vieles mehr zu unseren videos hier
unten ist der link wie ihr ein mitglied
werdet bei patchen und die heimischen
wir sehen uns nächste woche wieder hier
sehen uns nächste woche und ich halte
euch die daumen
bis bald
[Musik]